[Music]
this morning on the dish restaurateur
Hollis well Silverman she's behind not
just one but three new establishments in
the Capitol Hill Neighborhood of
Washington DC we visited Silverman for a
meal and a chat about how her creative
approach could perhaps change the
culinary industry as a whole
walk into this space on Capitol Hill and
no matter your taste move or degree of
hunger you've got choices
there's the Italian inspired La Colina a
cocktail bar known as the wells
and then the duck and the peach a
seasonal Twist on New American Cuisine
coined with love so the peach is a
nickname for my daughter and the duck is
a nickname for my old black lab so
ravioli to finish 62. for a restaurant
tour Hall as well Silverman it's a take
on the ultimate dinner party I wanted to
do something that was familiar was a
little bit nicer than maybe people could
prepare at home but not too pretentious
so really approachable we wanted to
create kind of small intimate spaces but
turning an old school in her
neighborhood into a passion project
wasn't exactly her wish come true
restaurants are an insane business so
most of them fail I never wanted to open
a restaurant but you say that with a
smiling thing well I feel like in the
world and especially after the pandemic
you have to have a smile on your face
with construction starting in early 2020
the first concept open within a year the
other two followed in mid-2021 there was
an opportunity to open these spaces and
I knew that if I let someone else do
this I would be not happy three
restaurants virtually in the same spot
what you know how
did you pull this off
uh with a great team a great team she
says that delivers great food like
kampachi Crudo with cucumber and avocado
puree carrots over sheep's alabne or
yogurt winter squash rice made with bear
Beret and Ethiopian spice blend and
topped with pumpkin seeds and shallot
it hits on the second bite and
Silverman's favorite must-have on the
menu rotisserie chicken with cilantro
Zug roasted chicken is my love language
and why is that whenever anyone needs
something or you drop a meal or someone
has a baby you're having a hard time I
typically roast a chicken and I give it
to people got it because a roast chicken
is a true sign of love and deliciousness
a lot of hallways in this joint we do
have a lot of hallways in this joint
leading to many things many many things
it starts with the floor plan three cons
steps that actually share just one
kitchen well nobody's supposed to know
that
so technically it's two restaurants in a
bar from the guest perspective but I
knew from my experience that in order to
have a successful business you need
volume so I designed something that I
felt people needed living here for so
long and being married and then without
kids married with dog married with kids
with the stroller without the stroller
and understanding that you need a little
bit of everything push your dough on top
and kind of get your fingers get the
divots in executive chef Katarina
petinito gave me a lesson on the art of
making three cheese ravioli oh wow I'm
getting the hang of this yeah that looks
great and offered her take on the
company line I would say she's probably
one of the greatest people I've worked
for she's very passionate about making
an environment that's safe and
encouraging for everyone to be in
pattonito says the kitchen is built on
efficient see we do all like the right
things we're recycling we're composting
we're using sustainable products we're
working with local farms and agriculture
to make sure that we're bringing in as
local ingredients and seasonal like
hyper seasonal ingredients and Silverman
threads her intention through everything
like an all women wine program and
executive team we're trying to change
the game we're trying to really create a
place where people feel welcome everyone
feels welcome
she got her start in San Diego in
Northern California with a degree in
Hospitality management later
transferring to DC with her Navy husband
where she landed in the view of Chef
Jose Andres Jose is an amazing leader
but he's also an amazing team member so
he knows how to build a team he knows
how to look at not only food but look at
beverages look at design look at all the
things and figure out how to make it
better and that's something that not
many people do she would become Chief
Operating Officer of his think food
group and over 10 years nearly tripled
his staff expanding his local brand into
a national Empire it enabled him to take
on big problems like world hunger
Silverman is tackling big issues too on
a smaller scale we're tackling tipping I
think that how tipping started is not
great I think that it leads
unfortunately to a lot out of unhealthy
cultures and work environments
so we do a service charge instead we pay
people a higher hourly rate and paying
people with their worth Fosters
creativity
as we saw with pastry chef and ice cream
Queen Rochelle Cooper and
say we have a lot of fun with it the
team gets creative and comes up with
great flavors like the dough ball
trouble oh my gosh the diet goes out the
window here
experimentation is the spirit of the
wells where jyn is front and center oh
okay you got me at the Ice Cube well
it's really a good cocktail is about the
ice and then we just add a bunch of
fresh Citrus and Botanicals and herbs
and spices to bring out the flavor of
the gym wow when do you open
running these three concepts is a labor
of love Silverman doesn't shy away from
you know I can't change certain things
but like this is what I can do so people
can come in they know that they're going
to have a great time they feel like they
can enjoy someone across the table from
them and that's how I can
hopefully put a little bit more joy into
people's lives
love the cocktail bar we couldn't tell
even though I'm on dry January I had to
taste and this is one of her fascinating
Blends it's a classic curb take on the
gin and tonic with juniper berries lemon
lime so yummy I love that what was the
ice cream again don't double dough uh no
sugar-free January yeah no no it was
unbelievable good stuff it all looked
delicious yes it did